PROFESSOR: OK, ready for more?
I defined a problem for you.
Now let's address it.
Said that if we have one
coordinate system, and if we
have some vector, q, that's
defined as a second-rank
tensor, aij times some other
vector p sub j--
and let me digress in passing.
I am very careful to say "a
second-rank tensor" and not a
"second-order tensor," because
higher-order order terms means
negligible and non-important.
And when I say "second-order
tensor," I don't mean to say
it's not important
and negligible.
It's very important, so I say
"rank," which has some sort of
dignity to it.
So I don't like the term
"order," because it has
another meaning.
OK, so here is a tensor that
relates a vector pj to give us
the components of a vector qi.
If we change coordinate system,
the components of p,
representing exactly one in the
same vector, wink on and
off and take different values.
The values for q take on
different values, and
therefore, of necessity, the
three by three array of
coefficients, which relates
these different numbers, must
also change its numerical
values.
And I hopefully convinced you
at the end of last hour that
there's times when you might
actually want to do this when
you're cutting out a particular
sample from a
single-crystal specimen.
How do we get the new tensor
in terms of the direction
cosine scheme that specifies
the change of axes and the
original tensor?
So I am going to refer to my
notes quite closely here,
because I want it to come out
pretty and not have to
redefine variables
when I'm done.
So let's start with the original
tensor relation, q
sub i equals aij
times p sub j.
Now, what we want is something
of the form q sub i prime
equals aij prime times
p sub j prime.
And we know the relations
forward and reverse in terms
of the direction cosine scheme
cij So let's begin by writing
qi prime in terms of
qi And we know how
that is going to transform.
It's going to be elements of
the direction cosine scheme
cim times q sub m.
So that will give me the i-th
component of q in the new
coordinate system.
I know how q arises from
the applied vector p.
So let me write qm in terms
of the applied pj.
And this is going to
be aij times--
be careful of my variables
here--
this is going to be a
ml times p sub l.
And that is going to, from my
definition of a second-rank
tensor, give me the m-th
component of q.
So far, so good.
I've got two different repeated
subscripts here, so
this is a double summation.
Now, I'll have what I want to
have, namely a q sub i prime
on the left-hand side and a p
sub j prime on the right-hand
side if I can express the
original components of p in
terms of the new components
of p.
And I do that by the reverse
transformation.
So let me now write a ml.
And then in place of p sub
l, I will write cjl
times p sub j prime.
Notice the inverted order
of the subscripts.
That is the reverse
transformation that's going to
give me p sub l.
So you really have now
what I'm after.
This is a triple summation
in m, l, and j.
I can write the terms that are
in what is going to be a
triple summation over
a product of terms.
I could write these terms
in any order.
So to simplify it, let me write
q sub i prime is equal
to cim cjl times a ml,
times p sub j prime.
And now, hotcha, I've got an
expression that has q prime on
the left and p prime on the
right, and paying close
attention to my notes so that
the subscripts all came out
the way I would like them to.
So what this says is that the
transform tensor aij prime is
going to be equal to,
by definition--
or what we've shown here,
it's going to be equal--
just picking off terms--
it's going to be
cim cjl times a ml.
Just picking off these terms.
m has no physical meaning,
because m simply is an index
of summation.
l has no specific meaning.
That is just an index
of summation.
But the i and the j
do have meaning.
They go with the i and j on the
particular tensor element
that we were attempting
to evaluate.
So in other words, to be
specific, if we want the new
value of the tensor element a1
2 prime, it's going to be c1
something, c2 something, and
those somethings m and l would
vary from 1 to 3.
So if I write this out not in
the reduced subscript notation
but put a summation sign in
there, so a12 prime is going
to be the sum over m and the
sum over l of terms c1m--
the first index is always 1--
c2 something--
first index is always 2--
and then m and l take on
all possible values.
OK, we've got two results.
We learned how to transform
a vector.
And a vector, if you will, is
simply a tensor of first rank.
And transforming the vector,
we summed over all three
components of the
original vector.
And the coefficients in
that summation were
one direction cosine.
Now we're transforming
a second-rank tensor.
Again, each new element is a
linear combination of all nine
of the elements in the original
tensor, and the
coefficients are a product
of two direction cosines.
So we've got two points.
Let's draw a line through them,
and we can say that, in
general, any new tensor
element of any rank--
and you could prove it through
exactly this method by going
up, now, to the third rank,
fourth rank, and so on, and
writing substitutions
of this form--
it turns out that a new tensor
element aijkl however far you
want to go, is going to be given
by a linear combination
of direction cosine element ciI,
cj capital J, ck capital
K, cl capital L, times however
far you have to go times
aijkl, and so on.
So these are the true indices.
These have physical meaning.
These have relevance
to how a particular
property will behave.
The capital I, capital J,
capital L, and so on, are what
we referred to last time
as dummy indices.
These are indices
of summation.
But the first index on
the direction cosines
has specific meaning.
They are tied to the indices on
the subscript of the term
that you would like
to evaluate.
So we've got now a very profound
relation for a tensor
of any rank.
And really, it just involves
substitutions using the
reverse or the forward
transformation until you get
one element on the one side
related to another element on
the right-hand side.
And this is a specific element
in the new tensor, in our
case, of the second-rank
tensor, aml.
This is all very abstract.
It is something that we'll have
to do a couple of times
for a real problem before you
see how it works out.
The number of elements that
figure into these
transformations is really
astronomical.
Suppose, for example, the tensor
involved were something
like the elastic stiffness
tensor, which is
represented by c.
And we need four subscripts.
This is a tensor
or fourth rank.
If we wanted to transform a
particular stiffness to a new
coordinate system, we would need
a summation ci capital I,
cj capital J, ck capital K, cl
capital L, times all of the
elements in the original
tensor, aijkl.
A fourth-rank tensor consists
of an array of 9 by 9 terms.
So there are 81 of these.
We'd have four direction cosines
out in front, and
there would be a total of 81
times 5 characters that we
would have to write.
So to do the complete tensor
transformation, we would have
to write on the order of 400
quantities to get just one of
the 81 elements in the
new transform tensor.
So the total number of elements
we'd have to write to
do this would be 81
squared times 5.
That's a lot of elements.
We'll do a few of these
transformations directly, but
let me assure you that if we
do a transformation that is
going to involve symmetry, a lot
of the direction cosines,
if we're lucky, will be 0.
So it's not quite as onerous
as it seems.
So we would make use of this
sort of formalism if we wanted
to go from one set of reference
axes to a new set
that might represent a special
specimen that we
cut out of a crystal.
But there's another formal way
in which we could make very
profound and non-intuitive
use of these relations.
Crystals, except for the
abominable triclinic crystals,
have symmetry.
If a crystal has symmetry, you
can transform the solid
physically by that symmetry
operation.
And you have to measure
the same
property before and after.
So suppose we have a crystal
that has a twofold axis.
And this crystal is something
that looks like this.
So this is side A, and this is
side B. We could move the
crystal by a 180-degree
rotation.
Put it down.
I won't draw it, because it's
going to look exactly the
same, except now this thing--
I won't draw, and
I do draw it--
this is face A, and this is face
B. If we had electrodes
on the crystal before and after
that transformation, we
have to measure, let's say,
the same electrical
conductivity for both
orientations of the crystal.
Now, moving a crystal relative
to some coordinate system,
relative to a pair of electrodes
that we're
fastening onto the crystal, is
exactly the same thing as
doing the reverse transformation
of the
coordinate system.
That's a vague, strange-sounding
term.
So suppose we have a crystal
with a fourfold axis with four
faces, A, B, C, D. And here
are our electrodes.
To move the crystal relative
to the electrodes by a
90-degree rotation would involve
rotating face D up to
this location.
A would move to this location.
C would move to this location.
B would move to this location,
and we'd fasten electrodes on
the crystal again.
If the crystal originally had a
coordinate system such that
this were X1 and this is X2,
moving the electrodes onto a
different direction on the
crystal is the same as moving
the crystal in the
opposite sense.
So we could either envision
moving the crystal relative to
the electrodes like this, or we
could move the electrodes
relative to the crystal by the
reverse transformation.
And the result is the same.
So what I'm saying is that if
a crystal has symmetry--
and let me be specific and
suppose that our crystal has a
twofold rotation
axis along X3.
Let's ask how that twofold
access would change the
coordinate system relative
to the crystal.
That's the same as moving the
crystal relative to the
coordinate system.
It's going to take X1 and move
it to this location X1 prime.
It's going to take
X2 and move it
through 180-degree rotation.
This is going to be X2 prime.
And if the twofold axis
is along X3, X3 prime
is the same as X3.
So what is the direction
cosine scheme for
this change of axes?
You might immediately start
working and saying, well, C11
is the cosine of the angle
between X1 prime and X1.
That's 180 degrees.
Cosine of 180 degrees
is minus 1.
But let me remind you that the
direction cosine scheme, c ij,
simply gives us the relation
between the new axes x sub i
prime and the old
axes, x sub j.
So let me, just by inspection,
write down the relation
between these two sets of
coordinate systems.
So X1 prime is equal
to minus X1.
X2 prime is equal to minus X2.
X3 prime is equal to X3.
So the direction cosine scheme
for this particular
transformation is simply minus
1 0 0, 0 minus 1 0, 0 0 1.
So I just evaluated a
nine-element direction cosine
scheme by inspection, if I can
write the relation between the
coordinate system before and
after the transformation.
OK?
And as we examine higher
symmetry, the same is going to
be true for the threefold axis,
let's say, along the 1,
1, 1 direction of a cubic
crystal, for a sixfold
axis, and so on.
So we'll be able to write the
direction cosine schemes for a
symmetry transformation
simply by inspection.
So for a twofold axis along X3,
this is the form of the
direction cosine scheme.
So now let me transform the
elements of a second-rank
tensor term by term and
see what we get.
Suppose I want--
let's stick with conductivity
as an example.
Suppose I want the value for
the conductivity element
sigma1 1 prime.
That's going to be c1 something,
c1 something,
because these are the elements
that go in here, times every
element of a conductivity
tensor sigma lm.
The only element of the form c1
something that is non-zero
in this row c11, c12, c13,
is the term c11.
In the same way in the same row,
the only term of the form
c1 something is c11.
So this is going to be simply
c11 times c11 times sigma11.
That's the only term
that survives.
c11 has a numerical value of
minus 1, and that says that
sigma11 prime is equal
to sigma11.
So is there any constraint, any
restriction on sigma 11?
No, sigma11 could be
anything it likes.
So there's no constraint.
Let's do another element.
Let's see what sigma12
prime would be.
This will be c1 something times
c2 something times sigma
something something.
The only element of the
form c1 something that
is non-zero is c11.
So I'll put in a 1 for the l.
The only direction cosine
element of the form c2
something which is
non-zero is c22.
So I'll put in c22 and
let n be equal to 2.
c11 is minus 1, c22
is minus 1.
So again, this gives us
something not terribly
interesting.
Sigma 12 prime is equal
to sigma 12.
So there's no constraint, at
which point you're probably
getting very restive,
say, this is
not telling us anything.
So let me shake you up
by doing one further
transformation, and that is to
find the value for c13 prime.
And that would be
c1 something, c3
something times sigma lm.
The only form of this term of
the form c1 something, that's
non-zero is c11,
as we've seen.
So I'll put in just that
single term and
replace l by 1.
The term of the form
c3 something that
is non-zero is c33.
And I'll put in a 3 for m, and
this is then c11 times c33
times sigma13.
1, And c11 is minus 1.
c33 is plus 1.
And that says that sigma13
prime is minus sigma13.
But if this is a symmetry
transformation, the tensor has
to remain invariant.
And if we're to have sigma13
equals minus sigma13, there's
only one number that can make
that claim, and that's 0.
So sigma13 is identically 0.
And that places a rather severe
constraint on the way
in which the crystal is going to
relate an applied electric
field to a current flow.
Sigma11 is anything.
Sigma12 is anything.
Sigma13 has to be
identically 0.
Now, let's cut to
the bottom line.
The direction cosine scheme is
diagonal, so we can say that
for any element that we pick to
transform sigma ij prime is
going to be cii, the diagonal
term which has the second
subscript equal to the first,
times cjj times sigma ij.
And this says that if we have
i or j is equal to 3, then
sigma ij has to be 0, because
we're going to have a minus 1
times a plus 1.
If neither i or j is equal to 3,
then again, we will have a
minus 1 times a minus 1.
There will be no constraint.
And the only final possibility
is that both i and j
are equal to 3.
That would be the single
element c33.
Then we would have plus 1 times
plus 1 as the product of
direction cosines, and there
will be no constraint.
So for a crystal that has a
twofold axis, and in which
that twofold axis is along the
direction of x3, the form of
the tensor will be sigma11,
sigma12, 0, sigma21, sigma22,
0, sigma31, that's going to be
equal to 0, and sigma33 has no
constraints.
So rather than having nine
elements, there are only five
independent elements
rather than nine.
And there is now another
relation that can occur in a
second-rank tensor.
The off-diagonal terms sigma12
and sigma21 do
not have to be related.
But for most--
but not all--
most second-rank tensor
properties happily have sigma
ij identical to sigma ji.
In other words, the tensor
is symmetric across
its principal diagonal.
That is a condition that does
not arise from symmetry That
depends on the specific
physical property.
So let me emphasize
that this depends
on the tensor property.
And for a great many physical
properties--
conductivity, diffusivity,
permeability, susceptibility--
you can show that the tensor
has to be symmetric.
But there are a lot of tensors,
particularly for the
more obscure physical
properties, where to my
knowledge, this proof has
never been given.
And along the same lines, it
is well known that there is
one physical property for
which this is not true.
This is the thermal electricity
tensor.
So for at least one property,
you can show for sure that the
tensor does not have to be
symmetric and that for a
crystal of symmetry 2, this
term and this term are
definitely not equal.
All right, let us do another
transformation for another
symmetry, and we can see that
it goes fast when the
direction cosine scheme
is relatively sparse.
Let's ask the restrictions,
if any, that
are imposed by inversion.
So what is the direction
cosine scheme here?
Here's x1, here's
x2, here's x3.
Then operation of inversion at
the intersection of these axes
will invert the direction
of x1 prime to here.
It'll invert the direction
of x2 prime here.
It will invert the direction
of x3 prime to here.
So the relation between the
reference axes is that x1
prime is equal to minus x1.
x2 prime is equal to minus x2.
x3 prime is equal to minus x3,
so that the form of the
direction cosine scheme crj
is minus 1, 00, 0 minus
1 0, 00 minus 1.
Slightly different from that for
a two-fold axis for which
the first two diagonal elements
were minus 1, the
third one was 0.
Well, let's jump right
to it and see if we
can generalize this.
It's a diagonal direction cosine
scheme once again.
And this says that if we
transform a particular element
sigma ij, it's going to be given
by cil, cjm, sigma lm,
where l and m are variables
of summation.
The only ones that survive are
the ones for which i equals l
and for which j equals m.
So it's going to be cii,
cjj times sigma ij.
Regardless of the values of i
and j, the diagonal terms are
always minus 1.
And therefore, sigma ij prime is
always going to turn out to
be equal to sigma ij, so
there's going to be no
constraint on any element.
And this shortens the job that's
facing us immeasurably.
So let me write that down,
because that's important.
Inversion imposes no constraint
on any second-rank
tensor property.
So if we stay with monoclinic
crystals, we looked at
symmetry 2.
Symmetry 2 over m is equal
to 2 with an inversion
center put on it.
But inversion doesn't require
anything, so the symmetry
constraints for 2 over m
have to be the same as
for symmetry 2.
We look at the constraints that
might be imposed by a
mirror plane.
A mirror plane plus inversion
is 2 over m.
2 over m has to be
the same as 2.
So this will be the same as 2.
And now we've shown that for
any monoclinic crystal,
regardless of whether the
symmetry, the point group, is
2m or 2 over m, the form
of the tensor has to
be exactly the same.
So for any monoclinic crystal,
namely 2m or 2 over m, this is
the form of the tensor where
the twofold axis, again, is
along x3, the mirror plane would
have to be perpendicular
to x3, and for 2 over m, both
of the preceding conditions.
So how about that?
Let me issue a caveat, because
we're almost out of time.
There are five independent
elements.
And that's true.
But elements sigma12, sigma21,
sigma13, and sigma31 are 0
only for this arrangement
of axes relative to
the symmetry elements.
If you wanted to take a
different set of axes, you
know how to get the tensor
for that set of axes.
Each tensor element is going
to be given by a linear
combination of these five
non-zero elements.
And if the orientation of the
axes relative to the symmetry
elements is quite general, all
nine elements of the tensor
will be non-zero.
There will be only five
independent numbers, which
composes each of those nine
elements, and they will be
given by a product of two
direction cosines, sometimes
each of these five non-zero
elements.
But there will be no zeros in
this array at all for an
arbitrary set of coordinate
systems.
Something that I think I'll ask
you to do as a problem,
because it's really easy
to do, if the tensor is
symmetric, which most of them
are, one thing that you can
show quite directly is that
a symmetric tensor remains
symmetric for any arbitrary
change of axes.
And that, again, is something
that's fairly easy to prove,
and I'll let you have the fun
and exhilaration of doing that
for yourself.
OK, so this means that for
everything except thermal
electricity, you really have
to transform, at most, only
six elements if you go from one
coordinate system to another.
That's still a lot, but it's
considerably better than
transforming all nine.
So if the tensor originally is
symmetric in one coordinate
system, it stays symmetric in
any other coordinate system.
Now, one thing that
I should mention--
I passed over it rather
quickly--
we said that a property of a
direction cosine scheme is
that it is what's called a
unitary transformation.
And it has the property that
the determinant of the
coefficients is plus
1 if the axis
retains the same chirality.
The determinant is minus 1 if
you change the handedness.
That is only true for what is
called a measure-preserving
transformation.
That's what it's called.
And when it's a
measure-preserving
transformation, then the
direction cosine scheme is a
unitary matrix.
What is measure-preserving
transformation?
If it's a right-handed system
beforehand, there's no squishing.
It doesn't go to an oblique
coordinate system.
Cartesian stays Cartesian.
If the reference axes are of
equal lengths, they don't
stretch upon the
transformation.
You can define transformations
like that if you like, where
the angles between them go from
orthogonal to oblique
after the transformation, and
the units of length along the
three axes change dimension.
But then the determinant of the
coefficients is not unity,
and a lot of the nice,
convenient properties that
we've seen here do not hold.
All right, that is a good
place to stop, I think.
Next week, no quiz.
If you came in late, we're
going to postpone
the quiz for a week.
And let's see, look at all I
can ask you just after one
lecture on tensors.
What we will do next is explore
the form of the
tensors for other crystal
symmetries.
It goes fairly quickly.
And then having done all that,
I'll show you how you can
determine the symmetry
constraints by inspection for
a tensor of any rank.
And you're going to despise me
for that, but this was useful,
because we can get used to
manipulating the notation.
But there is a method called--
appropriately enough-- the
method of direct inspection
where you can very quickly and
very easily do the symmetry
transformations.
So all this and more will be
revealed next time, which is
going to be a lot more
beneficial than taking a quiz.